et la france est bien dans quelques
heures quelques heures avant la fin de
la coop 26 elle a annoncé qu'elle ne
financera plus de projets d'énergies
fossiles à l'étranger d'ici la fin 2022
une bonne décision mais insuffisant pour
lucile pinsson elle est directrice de l'
ong écologistes réclament financée en
liquide
il va falloir que la france fasse bien
plus si elle entend mettre la finance à
contribution pour tenir l'objectif de
limiter le réchauffement à 1,5 degré il
suffit pas seulement de s'engager à ne
plus financer de nouveaux projets
d'énergies fossiles à l'étranger et
encore comme je les dis il reste encore
des choses à faire sivola puisque le
diable va se cacher dans les détails de
l'application de cette mesure et il
s'agit d'accélérer le calendrier
d'application en renonçant dès
maintenant à soutenir certains projets
comme le projet de total energy arctique
lng 2 au plein coeur de l'arctique et
puis on appelle également le
gouvernement français à réguler les
activités des acteurs financiers privés
des assureurs les banques et aussi les
investisseurs français